[Music]
everybody's been at the top of the game
being down right they end up dead or in
jail on this always because of an ego
one more than they should want everybody
wants to be great everybody wants to be
Superfly they want to be us can you
dance with the devil longer love he's
about to step on your feet all our years
we have antibody any any why is that
because you have to know this because
bodies leave a stink I'm not talking
about his think that bring o police I'm
talking about a snake that you can never
shake just think that will bring you
down I get it freeze you not the briefs
to me okay it's not Sunday if you get it
then you hear what I'm saying I won't
have to cocaine business hey guys
welcome back to another et live you guys
just watched a new scene from the new
movie super fly and in studio today we
have mr. Trevor Jackson who plays priest
in the film be sure to check that out on
June 13th how you feeling today true I'm
good you were super fly that movie thank
you thank you so much appreciate it down
to the wardrobe the hair the stunts I
mean you really did an amazing job thank
you so much I got to know about this
audition process yes but before we get
into that I want to go ahead and have a
shout out to our fans who are tuned in
right now if you're tuned in on youtube
or on Facebook be sure to send your
questions and I'll make sure Trevor gets
those answered for you by the end of
this show so we'll be checking those out
Trevor let's talk about this audition
process
let's do you really nailed this role I
mean what was it like when you got the
call that you would be priests in a
remake oh well actually Joe silver told
himself I auditioned twice and they're
like no we need somebody bigger he's too
young boy ah and then randomly they're
like Joseph won't you come okay okay so
I get my script I go over there and he
walks out and he's on his iPad I'm in
his house on the couch and he walks and
he was like anyone do this movie with us
super casual I was like yeah he's like
okay we are in it I just wanted to meet
you face to face and yeah we'll work on
your deal when you leave
what's in the car oh you were balling
you were to say to shocked wild man it's
like just were those things you work
toward your whole life and it happens
pretty crazy that is crazy one thing I
love about you is that you were so
adamant about doing your own stunts
again it's so clear you did jujitsu how
do you cope with her
okay don't know anything about it please
tell me it's a also African slaves they
were taken from Africa brought to Brazil
they weren't a lot to a trained martial
arts they went alone because they wanted
to overrun the slave master and they
want to get bigger and you know but they
were so they disguise it as a dance so
that the slave masters whenever would
ask what they were doing being dumb okay
well you definitely kicked butt and
Superfly one of the things I love the
most is to you and Michael were there
any injuries on set tell me no we worked
that was a very very long scene if he
always turn brings up he's I'm proud of
myself I'm 50 years old and I lasted all
day with the 21 year old jujitsu fighter
another thing I love about Superfly I
talked to Jason
last week you guys have such a bromance
that is so clear does that resonate
off-screen people when they see us
together they go hear that you go again
every time we're together and I think
that's why does so well on screen I
really actually love him as like a
brother it's very rare that you find
someone that you meet and then it's like
you guys click that immediately right
away especially men especially black men
I feel like we're always trying to each
other and somebody was like oh yeah no
competition yeah that's what it is that
was clear that was very clear on screen
now also talking about the fact that you
worked with big boy did you had scenes
directly with him but my first thing was
okay Trevor does music big boy
collaboration in the future yes I want
to know I played him records in Hughes
but he had no idea to music really I
played a music music what losers losing
the stuff and yeah
I'm gonna hit him up and try and get
some stuff going for sure I'll be sick
hi guys we're American crimes was like
full outcast right that full circle
outcast like knew another thing they got
they got the sound tried down pat wit
future he really brought it and that was
one of the things that was so big in the
original yeah what do you feel is the
what makes this remake timeless
um I think anything that's authentic to
humanity will always be timeless because
hopefully humans around for a long time
right so I think any story that has real
characters and real relationships
yeah and just something that's relatable
I think this movie we all know somebody
in this movie that we know our life and
and as the American dream you know you
go from nothing to something and
everything that glitters isn't gold
there's many a message in it and I also
love how strongly viewed that the women
are in the self they take very very
strong commanding roles which I totally
come in and respect like that Lex did a
really great job Grimm I was so
impressed with her she did great um we
gotta talk about this here because it
looks like the curls have bounced back
yes they when we were figuring it out I
was really pushing for the straight
because I'd seen the original and I was
like there's you just can't I don't want
to see a new movie and not at least see
the essence of the old movie so it said
it has to be trade they're gonna go
curly I was like no please so then we'd
figured out like we came to a medium
where it would be short and we were part
in the middle of me and Andrea the head
of the hair department and it turned out
looking awesome it's like a part of the
superhero outfit no way long coat boots
I was very adamant about boots I never
wanted to be in a sneaker only boots
only jeans only one coats yeah Batman it
really was
jason said he was he was kind of itching
to take some clothes from wardrobe was
there a piece that you're like it took
the rain I took a ring but I got payback
it turned green looks great looked real
yeah it did
and then I've been identic char with now
listen everybody loves you and groaning
so the reason I wanted to talk about
Harris because Aaron he has you know the
curly fro going and I'm just thinking
okay is he still gonna have this slicked
down here from Super Fly and he's going
through like depression because oh yeah
tell us tell the bronies fans is there
still hope for frizz Oh Ian Aaron next
theme I just hope Aaron finds someone
that deserves him okay and that season
for the beauty that he is you know least
he can ask for right just kicked to the
curb last season what's still man every
time I like see them I'm like still kind
of mad on the enzyme when you see
alright you guys seem to have like a
really good bond yeah we do is there a
text chain that you guys have offseason
yes it's called ish ish yeah what kind
of ish goes down in the text page
anything was going on you know
everybody's doing their thing so we're
always congratulating each other it's
just checking on each other we all try
to figure out when we're all in towns
and you know we eat or do something them
house a unit now I know yar is like your
baby sister we love seeing her on on
grown --is-- but I loved you in burning
sands and I feel like I kind of want a
little crossover to happen do you think
that they'll go there with Aaron maté
would he be a photographer that can be
cool I haven't I haven't seen anything
can you haven't told me anything I
haven't talked to the writers so
hopefully there's some fun stuff in
there for sure right do you know when
you guys are shooting August I don't
know the middle of August yeah we're all
excited it'll just be fun to see them
yeah it's not work so we're getting some
questions in matt from facebook says how
familiar were you with the original film
when you signed on for this project um I
wasn't super for me my dad made me watch
it when I was younger and then when I
found out I was auditioning I knew what
the movie was I knew the guy
w was when I watched it again and I
didn't even watch all of it because I
didn't want to repeat or redo anything I
wanted everything to feel fresh and
organic and not feel like I was trying
to mimic something right so yeah but I
still haven't watched it from top to
bottom since I've like been aim for
company in it so I have to do that now
right but I didn't want to do it
beforehand because it was there what do
you think for people that love the
original and you know they're glued to
that what do you think is your unique
spin to priests I just think me my youth
I'm just not this as old as Ron was when
he did it I'm 21 playing 27 so I just
think I kind of bring a different
different vibe I gave him an accent to
people thankfully nobody's asking what
accident Isco don't know sound like you
kind of talk like this yeah I think that
would be about it okay when you guys see
this he I don't know if I'm gonna say
it's better or worse but it's very
steamy
now you were talking about how much you
love your grown --is-- cast mates and
Chloe and Halle are also in that season
you guys need to collaborate yes we've
been saying that all the time every time
[Music]
they spill any little nuggets or any tea
on the on the run to tour with you no no
they didn't okay well you need to give
them some tips cuz you just came off to
her yeah it sort was fun they don't need
tips from you know they're amazingly
talented but yeah I had a great time
went to our first time playing guitar on
to her which is nerve-racking but very
fun and just performing songs that are
me this rub drives part one I just I got
to write every song and play guitar and
just really being controlling my vision
and even all the visuals from that album
I'm directing myself came up with the
treatment so people are getting the the
realest version of me and I couldn't ask
for anything more
rub jobs to is even more dramatic and
we're gonna talk about that music in a
second a lot of people are saying
they're gonna watch Superfly so that's
really good they're anticipating it
speaking on of your music rough draft is
part one of three I wanted to I just
wrapped up to yesterday okay - yesterday
I was like this is it this is the order
I'm not taking because literally I've
had it done for a long time but I'll
make a new song and exchange one song
change one take two songs out add five
more songs but then I finally me and my
cousin rashon good song and that was
like the final piece I put on that right
turn the sake Kevin hi Kevin Kevin from
facebook says what's the most important
thing you've learned from growing up in
showbiz cuz you've been in this what
since six three seven okay yeah I'd say
just it's crazy I there's so many things
I care about and so many things I don't
care about and I think that's important
what you care about what you don't get
about you care about the work and you
care about people you care about
happiness care about those things
it'll be fine but once you start caring
about all this stuff even though it's
beautiful or whatever when people fall
in love with this it's when it kind of
goes downhill I feel like for most
people so I just try and stay to myself
do the work and you know speak for
itself don't get and I say don't give
the world too much you're so because I
have the ability to control you I know a
lot of people who I'll be with them like
on a regular day in their in their
phones you know I mean but you know
social media has that effect so many
people feel like they have to compare
their lives
sad it's so sad actually how do you feel
how do you stay grounded in like keep
yourself focused in social media heavy
world yeah no I pray a lot but for me I
try not to be on there too much I'll
just pose what I have to post you know
in terms of you know what I'm promoting
or things like that but you got to keep
your life your life I mean I thought the
best moments are never recorded you know
I think it's beautiful you know people
go and get the homeless but like why are
you getting record doing that yeah not
to just do it but most people just do it
cause like a worldstar oppose me or
somebody oppose me if I do a good thing
I guess is a good incentive but come on
we gotta be good with ourselves yeah and
how do you feel you stay like you said
good with yourself being in social media
like you said and being in this business
first
it can be easy to lose yourself did you
feel like there was ever a moment where
you wanted to give up and this is
absolutely when was that moment for you
that moment comes and goes you know I
mean and it went and he came in and went
a many a time when I was growing up and
you know being told no I'm just trying
and trying and not working actually
before American crime I was gonna quit
for a minute music and I went out for
snowfall like nine times I didn't then I
had one audition for American time of
moms like just go just go alright so I
went I didn't even study I just got
there grinding the lines cold reading in
the audition room felt like excellent
gonna bring you back for Network huh
didn't even got it and then I think
filming that working with Tim heightened
Alyssa T Hoffman Andre Regina John
Ridley just watching how they all worked
in the directing I really fell in love
with directing after American crime and
then Bernie sands I fell even deeper
into the love for acting God oh well
let's stick with super super fly cuz you
did really well in this one thank you
but yes for the next one Kyle from
Facebook hi Kyle he says as an actor do
you prefer performing in TV or films
film film why I feel like cuz I know
more about the character from top to
bottom you know I know how he's gonna
start I know he's gonna hint so I can
put little things in there to make it
make more sense to me when you're in a
you don't really know the evolution of a
character in a TV show you don't know
who's gonna go into the writers show up
at the table reading you're like okay
this will you know but when you get a
movie you can see it from top to bottom
and then decide how you go right now I
love that you're staying and acting but
you're really great in music as well so
you can kind of juggle both you just
dropped a new music video and what I
really loved about it is the imagery
that you put in it is lit literally
feels like the story of Adam and Eve yes
that was yeah no we were yeah the song
me my brother
in the in the room listening to the song
this is just a love song what's the
greatest love story ever told Adam and
Eve I'm saying and there's no love
server they're a little bad in it or a
little confusion or craziness I wanted
that I feel like but that's almost like
what you know I feel like that
represents you know when two people in
love and they make love it represents
that it's like we are part of each other
we are each other and that's kind of
what I wanted to show I'm and I love the
surprise most people think exactly I
love that I love that about the video
and it was everything I came up with in
my mind you know I mean it was
everything we thought about me and my
brother's child of pulling her at my
side we made that at the house we're
like how could we do this because when
we brought this up to the label and
people my god we don't the budget is
like trust me we can make it happen I
know what to do don't worry now do you
feel like you've ever met your rib or
you're not even thinking about dating
right now that's such a good question no
yes maybe never know you never know I
think you know when you've been you know
cuz your rib could be somebody that
wasn't your rib and then later
you know some of you men passing or
someone that you were with in the past
and they come back ready just you don't
know you kind of taking it day by day
that's the hardest thing though I'd say
with anything is love especially when
you're in this because then the more you
do is like you for real are you real
I've had a few times I've had people
tell me I didn't know who you are and
then we like went on their phone but she
like went to look something up and I was
looking at her phone and it said Trevor
check okay that's cool right rough draft
seems to deal with love and growth what
do you feel is the hardest lesson that
you've learned in a relationship hmm
hardest lesson that I've learned I think
jealousy I had to get over that I'm
still not fully over it but I'm like I'm
really like jealous personal really yeah
but I just had to go out a bit I think
but it's crazy my first relationship I
wasn't jealous at all second
relationship extremely jealous you know
and then now it's just like I know I'm
trying to find that balance of like
caring enough to worry you know cuz even
women say they won't but they want you
to be like oh my god it was that and
they love that you know it means you're
trying you know you're not you do if
you're with somebody and he's like he
cares a little bit well well that's good
that you're learning though you're
learning and you're expressing that
through your music I'm going back to you
because I'm really interested in now cuz
you keep saying it okay so if you're
with someone right and he yes it did and
he never asked you about when you be
like a little worried when you wonder
like no I think that like you said to
each his own every experience teaches
you something yeah feel like I've kind
of moved past that
don't you but back on you yeah I want to
talk about rough draft - yes and what do
you think is going to be the theme of
this next draft it's much more mellow
than drugs that's part one drug jobs but
even like from the cover the covers vent
like a rock star
excuse me bunch of songs you know that
are kind of
I mean I'm tempo there's are some rows
on there but it's very kind of like hey
yeah and this one is more so everything
is like about a specific not that
everything in that wasn't a specific
experience but it's just I think it's
just going deeper I feel like each each
album I make I pull back a layer and so
the layer has been pulled back further
on this one and you know there's just
deeper concepts I'm talking about I'm
talking about people have changed
throughout the course of my career and
as things have happened people of you
know I've lost people I've gained
friends but it's his dope I like it
actually better and do you know when
that draft is gonna be really trying to
do it in September awesome yeah so you
got a lot going on yeah okay should some
videos did it going now since you're
you're an actor and you're in music I
always think like is there someone that
you would want to do a biopic on a
musician or someone that you're inspired
by have you ever thought of that okay
Marvin Gaye it would be cool I'm gonna
do like a Cab Calloway maybe but
Muhammad Ali I definitely want to do too
that would be really good for you okay
well before we uh well before we go
Susie has a question and then we're
gonna end on superfly Susie from
facebook says what can you tell me about
your upcoming short unregistered I can
tell you that it's based in a futuristic
world and it's a love story all along
that's really all I can say about is a
love story and things get a little fishy
what do you mean by fishy
I mean smelly I'm joking I just mean
that gives a little gets a little weird
okay yeah but it's good though it's a
fairly no story directed by Sophie as
she killed it produced by Loog written
by hearing Dignam my co-star Dylan pin
[Music]
okay and when does that come out just so
they know I have no idea you don't know
but hopefully soon well super fly again
is out on June 13th but what is the big
takeaway that you hope our audience
feels once they leave that the
larger than life I think my favorite one
is unity I feel like like I was saying
before we always try and outdo each
other whatever but me and Eddie's
relationship the character Jason plays
is so I think it should mirror how we
should be towards each other more I mean
more lenient more relying on each other
not feeling like everything has to go
through us and just together man a world
of separatism it's horrible well you
feel very passionately about that and I
would agree there is a lot going on in
the world right now but you're making
your mark you making your impact as far
as superfly you guys can go ahead and
see that worldwide this Wednesday on
June 13th Trevor will be playing priest
and he does a phenomenal job so be sure
to go to your theater and check that out
check that yep all right we'll see you
guys later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]